Okay, hopefully everyone can hear.
Welcome. Good evening if you're in
Europe or good morning if you're um
elsewhere. Um we're here now for Pakan's
uh master class in graph data science.
Um hope many of you joined the excellent
session yesterday which Paco PCO hosted.
Um, I won't give a huge introduction to
Paco, not least because I don't know how
I could describe Paco, apart from as a
guru in our space, who's one of the most
exciting people um that I talk to in the
community, genuine sponge of knowledge,
and I always come away from our
conversations feeling positively infused
and um and and learning a lot. So, I'm
really looking forward to this um
session. Um so yeah, last last thing is
to just um as always thank our sponsors
for helping make this this happen. Semi
technologies and and weate and um with
that over to you Paco.
>> Thank you. Thank you very kindly James.
I I appreciate uh
all righty. Well, I'm really looking
forward to today. Um I I've really
enjoyed the sessions yesterday and the
community discussion and also just a lot
of discussions that we had uh
subsequently offline uh on on LinkedIn
and email and and uh and others. Uh so
uh I'm thoroughly looking forward to our
discussions here today
and I want to figure out certainly on
this platform what's the best way to
work on this but um I will be sharing my
screen uh most of what we'll be going
through is available in notebooks so it
works really well to show through the
browser um and also you can you can be
having this in a different browser
window and going along with it um but I
also want to try to shift back and forth
so that I can catch uh questions in
chat. And um and I think just real
briefly while while I'm doing this
before I start sharing the screen uh
let me uh let me show my face here. Um I
want to be able to monitor the chat also
because uh there may be questions that
come up as far as when we're doing the
installation. Um so uh welcome all.
Thank you. Uh this is about graph-based
data science. This is a master class and
we'll be showing working in Python. Um
how you can use a lot of different types
of uh Python libraries. There's one in
particular called KG Lab. We've been
doing a lot of work to integrate other
libraries so that they have common
ground. And we'll be working through uh
different use cases uh using graph based
techniques uh and showing how these
integrate with the popular data science
tooling like pandas and net flatlib and
and numpy and b and things like that. Um
so uh I think probably the best way
we'll see how this works out but
probably the best way uh for this format
is we'll go through some different
points. I'll show you from my screen
what what I'm doing and you know we'll
spend some minutes doing that going
through whatever code that we're
covering and then I'll cut back to chat
because I I want to allow for a lot of
interaction. I'm not sure that
participants will be able to ask via
audio. So if I'm sharing something full
screen I I I wouldn't be able to see uh
uh without doing some some cut back into
chat. Um, also, you know, we definitely
want to uh include breaks during this
and um I'll be around during the breaks
generally uh to answer any questions. Uh
we've got a few hours here today and uh
definitely we've got enough material to
pack uh into that time. Um we will be
building off of a lot of the materials
that we had yesterday in the talk and I
just want to make those slides available
as a kind of a general background.
Um, so that's one of the first things
that I'll put in the chat here. Uh,
there's this talk. Let's see. It should
um,
and let me let me change my screen
around a little bit. There we go. Good.
Now I can see more chat. Um, so I I just
pasted in uh,
there's the talk slides that we had from
yesterday. There's actually a supererset
of those slides. There's a lot of links
and a lot of background information. um
if there's any particular parts that you
want to check for primary sources or
other uh repos things like that. Um so
that's one set of materials. Um the
other thing though is the actual GitHub
repo for the KGAB project and I'll paste
that in here now. Um, so that's
github.comaikab
and uh we're not going to have a a large
requirement on programming. You know,
the idea is if you can work with brief
Python programs, 20 lines or so, read
and write those, you're probably good to
go here. Um there if you want to get set
up with hands- on coding side, what
you'll need to do is uh download that
GitHub repo, clone it, and so there's
instructions and I can walk through some
of this. Let me go back to sharing. Um
if I can get my screen. Yeah, there we
go.
Um share screen.
Chrome tab. Uh good. I can just share
one tab at a time it looks like. So
that's probably a better thing. Um if
you go to this github.com derai
kgab um on github is our main repository
uh site.
And if you're not familiar with g using
GitHub uh they make it very convenient.
There's a green button up in the top
right here. versus code.
And there's a few different ways to work
on things. The easiest way I find is if
you have u if you copy and paste this
URL, it'll say github.com der kg.get.
Okay, so that'll give you a URL and then
um go into the command line and actually
I can walk you through it. I'm not going
to do the entire thing. Um, let me share
my command line. It's probably better
the whole screen. Yeah.
Um,
so if you're at a command line and you
want to install,
um, if you haven't used get before. Um,
let's dig this up real quick. Okay. Um,
so if you say for any repo, if you get
that URL for the repo, you can say get
clone and then give it the URL. Hit
return. It'll start to download from get
and it'll create a new directory which
is the name of the repo. In this case,
it would create the kijili lab repo with
all the source underneath it. Um, so if
you're not set up already, take that
step.
And once you do that, then you'll
connect into a repo. Um, I already have
it installed, so I'm not going to
overwrite it, but you'll end up with
something that looks very much like this
kab. and it will have these different
files that have been downloaded. Um, in
particular,
uh, there's some information for being
able to install the required
dependencies. Um, all the dependencies
are over here in a file called
requirements.ext.
Um, so let me cut back over to getting
started on things. Um, let's see.
Getting set up installation.
So, uh, I'll put this URL into the chat
and this is from our documentation.
Um, there's a brief note here that shows
about doing a get clone to install the
software and then once that's
downloaded, connect into the directory
that it creates. Once you do that, then
you can do just simply pip install-r
requirements.txt.
So that'll that's a typical way in
Python to uh load up the the
dependencies the different libraries
that are used by kgab.
If you are using instead of pip then
there's also instructions here for using
um to create an environment if you want
or add to an existing environment
otherwise if you're familiar with using
but we've got environment
and then once you do that you can say
activate kglab. So you want to do one or
the other. Um probably don't wouldn't
need to do both. Um the other thing is
that if you don't have it installed
already, we will be using Jupiter uh to
to walk through the different coding
examples, different parts of the
tutorial. Um so there's instructions
here for installing Jupyter Lab or if
you use how to install Jupyter Lab off
of cond.
Um we've tried this out on a wide range
of different systems. um gotten a lot of
feedback. Try to make this as general as
possible. So I'm
I'm personally using Mac and Ubuntu. I
have two different laptops. Um the
Abuntu laptop is a Kfocus and it's
pretty much the same thing. If you
launch an Ubuntu instance in the cloud,
it's very much like that. Um so I've
been checking back and forth. I have
other colleagues who've been checking
this out on Windows. Hopefully this
installer instruction will get you
through depending on your operating
system.
Um,
and then once you're set up with
Jupiter, uh, inside of that KGLAB
directory, you can type Jupiter-lab and
it'll launch Jupiter.
Um, so having said that, let me cut back
and I'll pause sharing. Um, and let me
look through the the uh comments to see
if there's anything here in chat. Um,
great great question, McDonald. And yes,
James, answer that. We will be recording
this. Um,
Luis, I installed KGLab dependencies
via. Uh, uh, yeah, you know, uh, good
point, Luis. Yeah, I don't know quite
what it is with, but it it it takes
longer to install through than it does
through Pi, uh, through pit. Um and and
it is a number of of uh different uh
libraries on which we're we're building.
Um certainly there's a number of them
and that's kind of the goal is that
we're trying to pull together a lot of
different disparate parts and create a
new abstraction layer that's like common
ground between them because there wasn't
a whole lot of common ground before. Um
so I will definitely you know Mia Kalpa
we've definitely tried to air on the
side of including a lot of stuff. It is
a pretty large build. Um I think you
know the saving grace is that with pi
you get a wheel and so you can just sort
of download the binary um is in some
cases. Um but it sounds like so far this
is going okay
if we are unable to install. Natalie
good question. Um yes if there's any
problems with the installation well
number one let me know. We want to
troubleshoot that. Um, and especially if
you can provide a a
any kind of information on a GitHub
issue, that'll help. But certainly
you'll be able to follow along if you
aren't able to install. Now, what I'm
going to do is go through each of these
different notebooks, each section in the
tutorial. I'll be going through it line
by line and I'm going to show you uh,
you know, running all of these and talk
through also, you know, what some of the
backgrounds. So we'll be chasing some of
the links are included in the notebooks
um to show the context in the background
before we execute the code. Um and then
you have the code as well if you want to
uh you know run this later. Um I really
like to package these tutorials in
notebooks because then you can go back
and kind of play what if and if you
change some of the parameters what
happens. Um I find that that's that's
really helpful for learning some of
these libraries. Again, we've tried to
simplify the layer of the abstraction of
how they're used. And so there's
generally a lot going on behind the
scenes when you're using different parts
of KGLAB. And trying to change some of
the parameters and see how it's
different uh can be very instructive to
learn. Uh yeah, Natalie, yes, that makes
a sense. Definitely. I run into that a
lot in tutorials where, you know, uh, if
you're if you're at work, um, employers
may have other policies about
downloading code externally or there may
be security requirements on laptops. Um,
and some of that needs to be vetted. I
know what you mean. Okay, great. Well,
it sounds like we're we're uh getting
through the installations. Um what I
want to shift over to next is let me
unpause sharing and show
just really where we're at. Um here at
this t sorry at this URL um where we've
got the tutorial. If I scroll back up to
the top um there's a syllabus that
describes the course we're in right now.
Um so this is about kg lab and it's
about integration of a lot of different
libraries uh network x psl
uh pyshackle rdf lib pi viz a whole
bunch of different kinds of graphbased
libraries how do we make them speak more
fluently with common data science tools
like pandas and scikitlearn but also
really how do we how do we also get
these to use best practices for um
infrastructure and data engineering and
mlops um so you know making them so that
they speak fluently with with uh parquet
um for fast serialization so you can fit
into spark and rapids um and also how to
integrate with thing tools like rapids
so you can use GPUs
um so that's a lot of the rhyme and
reason about kg and we'll be reinforcing
that with with examples as we go through
today um as I mentioned the prerex uh
really if you can read 20 lines of
Python you're good to go um definitely
Having some interest in knowledge graph
is also a prerek here. Um if you have
some of the math background, you may
find parts of this more interesting. Um
we're not going to rely on having a
whole bunch of math here. We're going to
talk more about just working on Python,
but certainly there are some aspects uh
where we get into uh areas of algebra,
linear algebra, abstract algebra,
topology. Um there's a lot of math going
on behind the scenes here. So if that's
an interest of yours, you have that
background, um it actually comes in
really handy for making the code more
efficient to run uh when you're working
with knowledge graph and graph
algorithms. And if you have any
questions along those lines, uh
definitely uh love to talk about it. Um
the audience here you know people who
need to work with uh knowledge graphs uh
definitely Python developers data
scientists data engineers machine
learning engineers also for people on
the business side the technical leaders
who want hands-on implementation
experience um executives who are
interested in data strategy that
leverages knowledge graph capabilities
um and people who are interested in
working with personal knowledge graphs I
know I I talked with people in email uh
uh yesterday after the meetup and And I
know that there's a lot of interest in
personal knowledge graph and I'm going
to show a few examples of that but also
some of the directions of where we're
really heading on that too. Um the key
takeaways we have you know definitely
how to work with open source in Python
for building knowledge graph. Um but
also giving you coding examples that are
starting points that you can use in your
own projects. And we do have a very
active community around KGAB. Um, you
know, our developers are very interested
to hear more about your use cases. If
there's something that can be done to
customize or add features to support
your use cases, we're all ears. So, um,
you know, these coding examples can be
used as a starting point, but it's also
just kind of a lingua franka for for us
to be able to uh talk together about
what what else you may need that we
haven't, you know, added here yet or
integrated.
Um, a lot of what we'll be talking about
following on from the the the meetup
presentation yesterday is this notion of
blending different approaches that are
complimentary.
And I had a a section in the talk
yesterday about self-supervised
learning,
which is a way of saying if I have a
complex object, I can train a supervised
learning model on parts of the object
and then use the model to attempt to
predict the missing parts, the redacted
parts or ablated parts if you will. Um,
so self-supervised learning is becoming
a really interesting area of AI. um
particularly since it reduces some of
the requirements of having to label all
of your data. Instead, you can have
machine learning help to develop the
labels. This is really important in
large graphs, working with graphs, uh
because there's a lot of opportunities
to work with complex objects. Uh so it
fits pretty well for self-supervised
learning. But the other side of it too
is that in enterprise especially, you
end up with these large graphs, your
labels may not be correct or they may be
missing. Um so a lot of what we're going
to talk about today are really um you
know when you're building a graph what
are what are the techniques for building
it but then how do you start to test it
how do you start to do really some
engineering thinking about well you know
do I believe um all the annotations that
are in my graph and how can I test to
find out the ones that maybe I think
need closer review um so data quality
checks um inference uh different areas
is of being able to understand how again
doing data science with graphs.
Um as far as the outline uh you know
what we've had for the course really
reflects the different notebooks that we
have and it's also uh as you see over on
the left hand side I'm clicking this uh
this menu here. Um basically all of
these different sections correspond to
the notebooks that we have to show
today. the different code samples which
basically just follow this outline. So
we're going to go through a lot of
different areas of graph. Um don't
really need to to review that just yet.
Um okay, so that's what we're going to
cover today and let me check back now
and see about um if there's any
questions. Also, I want to say, you
know, please feel free ask questions at
any point. Um, I I I really love to
catch a lot of the questions when we're
in progress. Um, because I I think that
that provides a lot better context for
everybody. Um, so if you have any
questions, let me know. Um, and also,
you know, I'll I'll say again, I said
yesterday, but please feel free to link
up on LinkedIn, reach out. Um, I've
already scheduled to talk with some of
you folks uh about individual use cases.
Um, great question. Okay, Sarah uh want
to know how to connect different
ontologies in order to reuse existing
ones. Fantastic. Actually, that's the
first section we go through is about how
to reuse existing controlled
vocabularies to build up the ontology
you need. And then throughout the
tutorial uh sections today, we'll show
examples of how to uh extend those
existing vocabularies to fit better with
your use case. So we have a few examples
of taking a couple of different, you
know, two or three or four different
vocabularies that are well known and
then adding a little bit of owl or a
little bit of RDFS or SCAS or whatever
um to try to extend them for the use
case at hand.
Great question.
Let me see if there's other other
questions too.
Um all righty. Great. Well, I'm going to
cut back over to uh
yeah, great. I will unpause.
Let's see if there's I will unpause and
let me go back down here into
um what I'm going to do now is well
first off clear my screen.
Okay. So, I'm going to say Jupyter Lab
inside of the KG Lab uh directory.
And this will launch Jupiter.
Boom. Uh and it should automatically
redirect your browser and open up a tab.
Um if not, uh the default is it'll be
running on localhost colon 8888LAB.
And when you launch Jupiter from the
command line, it will give you
instructions about um how to to open it
up in a browser. Uh if that doesn't
happen automatically, um in some cases,
depending on your environment, there may
be a security key that's required. It'll
also print that out. So you can just
copy paste. Um but once you get there,
you should have uh something that looks
very much like this. Um, you should see
there's a launcher window and on on the
left hand side we've got the directory,
the KG lab directory.
We will be working mostly inside of a
subdirectory called examples. So if you
click down into examples, you'll see
we've got a bunch of different
notebooks. Um, ex0_0
ex1_0 on and on. And these correspond to
the different um actually they are what
generate these different sections in the
documentation. So the first part that
I'm going to look at is under
construction. Let me dig it up here.
It's called data and ontology sources.
And over in Jupiter that would be ex0_z.
So if you double click on that notebook.
Okay. We bring up the same thing.
and uh just wanted to talk through the
the uh data that we'll be working with
and some of the vocabularies we'll be
working with. Um this is the tutorial is
based on a progressive example. So we'll
we'll be using reusing this data over
and over and just kind of building on uh
at every step of the way. Um so first
off um the data is available under the
DAT subdirectory. Um, if you want to
take a look at it inside of Jupyter, you
back up to the top level, go to the DAT
directory, and then inside of there,
um,
there's, uh, a number of different
files. Um, in particular, there's the
food.com
uh, file. Uh, this is a lot of the raw
data that we downloaded from
a Kaggle data set. Um, and it's it's
linked over here. The same thing.
Um, let me bring it up. There's a a a
recipe aggregator uh called food.com. A
lot of recipes online. And there was a a
file uh that's open on Kaggle of uh
about a quarter of a million two 250,000
different recipes. And so we'll be using
just a subset of this. Um,
and
so we've done some preparation. Um, but
we'll be working with this file
recipes.csv.
And if you if you click on that over on
the left hand side, it'll dig up. Okay,
here's sort of the raw data that we
have. Um, and this is just a lot of
recipes. This is a subset that we'll
start out with. We'll use a bigger uh
supererset of this later on, but right
now this is about 250 recipes and it's a
CSV file. Um you know there's a few
different columns. It's a little bit
messy because the ingredients are all
sort of glombmed together into one
column. Um so I'll have to split that
out. Um
but uh I definitely want to give a shout
out to food.com um for the recipes that
they've published. Um, one of them a
very simple recipe. Uh, I have some
photos of my attempt at it, but it's
it's called Anytime Crepes. And, uh, my
my family loves crepes. I love to make
them. Um, I use a slightly different
recipe that involves using some beer,
but uh, kind of a family thing. But
anyway, um, here is
uh, Anytime Crepes on Food.com, and it's
very simple. It just really has like
three different ingredients, not that
much. Um,
so to get started, um, let's see. If you
notice on this recipe, sorry, sorry,
Anytime Crepes right here. If you
notice, it's the URL for this recipe is
food.comre recipetime
crepes-327593.
So there's a an ID number for each one
of these quarter of a million recipes.
ID 327593.
Um there's some other metadata about
this recipe. Uh if you look it it shows
that the preparation time is 8 minutes
and it's got the ingredients egg, milk,
and flour. Um and so for a very first
step here, what we'd like to do is
represent uh a num number of these
different recipes in a in a small
knowledge graph. And so we're interested
in how do we parse this CSV file and
then convert it into RDF. Um so the
first thing I'm going to do is up at the
very top of the notebook, there's a
small bit of administr um just so we get
the paths all set up.
And so always click the one at the top
if you're running through the tutorial.
And then I'll show just real quickly.
Here's uh ls here's a listing of the
files in the data directory. We'll be
working with recipes.csv.
And let me click through a bit more.
Okay, now we get to really the first
line of code. We're going to import
pandas pandas as pd. And then we're
going to read a CSV file. Just very
simple kind of thing to create a data
frame in pandas. Um so definitely you
know data science 101 here. Um we're
just going to load in that CSV file. We
have it as a data frame now. Um and we
can start manipulating it. So the first
thing is uh let's just break out these
the uh the ingredients. The ingredients
were currently all kind of glombmed
together. So what we're going to do is
break them out. Uh we'll identify this
one recipe in particular to explore. Uh
it's called Anytime Crepes and we have
its ID and there's the different fields.
Um,
and we're going to work on it as an
example. Um, now let me step back a bit
and going to the question that I I
believe Sarah had. Um, what we're going
to work with is is a a an ontology, a
collection of different vocabularies.
It's called Food On. It's really
interesting. Um, food on. I actually
have a couple of friends who've worked
on this project. Uh, Deborah McInness
out of RPI. um and uh and and some some
other folks out of UC Davis. Um there is
an ontology uh or actually a collection
of ontologies that describes about food
production like going all the way back
to talking about the different species
of plants uh that are you know being
used and harvested on a farm or orchard
and then going through like in this case
here they've got apples. For what it's
worth, I live on an apple orchard in
Northern California. So near and dear to
my heart, we've got an apple tree and
then we've got information about raw
apples and we've got information about
recipes for apples and then all of the
food production steps going into making
apple pie or canning sliced apples etc.
So food on is really taking a look at
our food chain and understanding all the
way back from like you know molecular
biology, genomics of the plant species
um on through
what are the physiological effects of
food allergies on different individuals
on through harvesting, production, yield
and then different forms of processing,
food distribution, nutritional
information etc. Quite an interesting
knowledge graph project.
Um
now inside of food on there's a couple
of vocabularies that we're going to take
a look at. One of them is a general
description of types of foods. This is
really more about a recipe.
Let me load this up. And we're loading
it up from Pearl. Uh takes a while.
And gosh, I hope Pearl is doing okay.
Yeah, it's actually it's not pearl, it's
get. Okay. Um I will load those up. Um I
definitely want to show you the results.
Ah, there we go. Okay, cool. So, here's
one of the ontologies uh inside of food
on and this one is called uh what to
make. They abbreviate it WTM. Um, but
it's uh it's part of a knowledge graph
or it's rather it's a controlled
vocabulary plus some data that's
populated about recipes that you can
make and then studying those recipes.
Um, so there's a lot of different kind
of information here. Some of it has to
do with food allergies, uh, flavors, but
in particular, you know, we're just
looking at the real simple parts as far
as modeling the ingredients and the
cooking times. So, we're going to be
using this relationship. WTM has
ingredient. And uh so, here's some
definitions of what is an ingredient.
And there's a link out to Marian
Webster, the definition of an
ingredient, uh and a label and
definition, and on and on and on. But
that's that's basically what this
vocabulary is giving us.
There's another vocabulary over here
that talks about uh sort of the
individual's
points of or entities data points that
populate that knowledge graph at food
on. And so for instance here um we have
allpurpose flour. Um let's take a look
at uh wheat.
Let me dig up a few more whole grain.
Oh, wheat flour. Okay. So, for our
anytime crepes recipe, it's got eggs,
it's got milk, it's got wheat. Um, all
of those are populated here under this
uh what to make uh
uh
recipe controlled vocabulary. So, we're
just going to reuse different
ingredients out of here, and these will
have a prefix ind. And oh, by the way,
the format over here, it's a little bit
weird. Um, this is using RDF triples.
It's not the easiest thing to read. It's
got a lot of like HTML
escaped characters. Um, we're going to
be using a slightly simpler version, uh,
called turtle TTL.
So, uh, basically what I was just
showing over here in this sort of XMLish
kind of thing, it maps to what we'll be
showing here in Turtle. Basically the
same thing. Um but the point I want to
make is that we'll be working with
starting with these two different
control vocabularies. One is about uh
different types of ingredients and one
is about different types of of u
relationships amongst food. And so uh
each of these is called a namespace. So
each vocabulary has a unique URL and
right here and you can use that the
underlying software can use that URL to
go out and look up definitions. Um and
quite frankly just what I did here look
up the URL and then you can track down
to what is the the individual entity
inside of there. And so that way when
you're working with knowledge graph
software, you can make uh requests
across the the web um to dig up metadata
or other information about what's being
represented in your graph.
Now a practice inside of um RDFlib um is
that we'll shorten this URL and we'll
have a prefix. Um it's just something
that makes it a lot easier to work with.
So for every unique URL, every
vocabulary that we're going to use will
have some unique prefix. Um, and so in
this case, we're got what to make, WTM,
and D for ingredients. Um, and it it
just it really abbreviates things and
makes it a lot simpler.
Um, and now, uh, let's see, let me run
this. Boom. Um,
so what I did was to, uh, just pull out
that row from the the data frame and
then evaluate it. Um, if you notice, uh,
the ingredients are listed as strings
and they're actually something that
could be evaluated in Python and once
Python evaluates it, it turns it into a
list. Um, so here we've got a list that
comes back and says the ingredients for
anytime grapes, it's eggs, milk, and
whole wheat flour. Now respectively when
you map that back into the the
ingredient control vocabulary and D that
becomes um IND chicken egg and D cow
milk and IND whole wheat flour. So we
have three known entities that describe
those ingredients.
And the the general idea there is you
just mix and match a lot of these
different controlled vocabularies to be
able to represent what you need to
represent. And if there's something
that's missing you can add to it. um the
way that we construct knowledge graphs
uh when we're building up RDF and and
also you know building up not just RDF
but owl and SCAS and other things on top
of it um we just we add it's a very
additive kind of process so uh you know
we we can start out by bringing in these
two controlled vocabularies and bring in
four or five or six others add some of
our own add some data analyze it go back
in add some more relationships We'll be
doing that throughout the day. Um, so I
I just want to stress that it makes it
very convenient to mix and match. Um, if
you want more details about food on, uh,
it's it's called a farm to fork
ontology. Um, I highly recommend, uh,
here's some primary sources describing
it. actually uh one of my friends whom
I'm not sure I think may even be here
today uh Charles Vardman uh out of out
of Notre Dame uh as lead author on
ontology design for material
transformation. Um so there's some some
great primary resources if you want to
check out more about this. Um,
and
in general, if you want to see what Food
would do, like a full-blown thing, um,
you know, a representation in a
knowledge graph using Foodon, um, here's
a recipe for banana blueberry almond
muffins. And, you know, you've got a
half dozen different ingredients. and
you've got its recommended usage for
different meals and courses, um, cooking
time and temperature, service for um, on
and on and on. Um, so, you know, you can
really build out on this this notion of
recipes. And the other thing I want to
stress is if you can do this for a
cooking recipe, then, you know, you can
use it for other kinds of recipes, too.
Whether we're talking about industrial
supply chain or drug discovery and
pharma um you know material science on
and on and on there's a lot of places in
the world where the idea of a recipe is
sort of the problem at hand and that's
what we're trying to illustrate here.
Um, one last point I I just want to
talk. We're using some data that is
about food.com and we're using this this
ontology out of food on we'll be adding
to it. Um, I I do I do want to point out
that you know these are relatively large
resources. Um, I have taken a subset so
that we can work with some very quick
examples as we're starting out. Um, so
we'll be using sort of a medium size,
non-trivial size that has about 300
nodes and 2,000 edges. So, uh, as far as
the number of recipes is about, well,
there's a certain number of recipes and
then a certain number of ingredients
that show up repeatedly in those
recipes, but it comes out to 300 nodes
about um, and again, the intent there is
I really just want to illustrate what's
going on with the algorithms and the
queries and the visualization. And you
know there's it's overkill to use
something larger. Um but realistically
we have source for you know taking this
up a few more orders of magnitude. Um
you know definitely if you were just
doing something raw with deep learning
you'd need like 10 the six elements
before deep learning really kicks in. Um
these days you can you know pull a lot
of different deep learning models. uh
especially for working with graph
networks, you can pull them off the
shelf and just retrain what's called
transfer learning. Um so realistically,
if you have, you know, 10 to the fifth,
you're probably good. Um but when you
want to run deep learning, uh graph AI,
um you definitely want to work with a a
more of a a mid to large size graph. Um
so 300 nodes is probably too small.
3,000 nodes still a little bit small.
30,000 nodes would work pretty well with
deep learning. Um and I also want to
stress the point that like on
contemporary laptops you know working
with millions of nodes is not a problem.
Um I've worked with cases in industry
where you know we had two three million
nodes in a graph. I could run it on a
laptop 5 years ago it would run fine. Uh
today's contemporary laptops are much
better especially if you have a GPU in
them. Um, okay. So, that's a lot of
overview of at least where the data is
coming from, where the vocabularies are
coming in from, and what we're going to
try to do. So, let me cut back over and
I'll pause sharing for a moment and see.
Okay, great. There's some questions.
Um,
okay, let me scroll back up and see
uh what's going on here. uh is is not
recognizable as an internal command. Um
uh Mark, if you're running running into
that that sounds like a a command line
interpreter uh might be catching
something. Um
oh in Windows. Okay, gotcha. Uh thank
you. Um
okay, so it looks like there might be a
Windows issue there. And I'll scroll
down more and see. Um
yeah, so uh great question also from uh
Luis and Brad. Yeah, the um the the
foodcom thing uh the full data set CSV
file that I was showing um you have to
download it from Kaggle and we didn't
want to get into the licensing of
redistributing that um but it is freely
available on Kaggle. But what we did do
is take a subset of it and the subset is
going to be in uh the directory under
the git clump. That should be there. Um
but not the full one. Um so I just sort
of showing that as as background
and um
uh Okay. Right. So you've got
recipes.csv, but you don't have the
fullfood.com. Exactly. So yeah, that
that's what I was showing on Kaggle. If
you really want to go back and look at
the entire database data set, it's
available on Kaggle. it's not necessary
for what we're doing here and so I've
taken a subset of it and also just I
didn't want to get messed up in in the
licensing issues. Um okay Barrett great
great thing uh prefix.cc yes absolutely
um and we'll make mention of prefix.cc
uh later on working with uh
with uh prefixes and namespaces. Um, but
it's an excellent tool uh for being able
to understand what prefix should I use
for this vocabulary that I want to
import. Um, very very much so. Yes. Um,
Luis had a question. Are there issues
with the same entity or relation being
defined in several vocabularies? Yeah,
that's a good point. Um, definitely this
happens. Now the thing is that when
you're working with a controlled
vocabulary and it has its unique URL or
its unique prefix to describe as a
placeholder for the URL um then you know
by definition it's out in that name
space that URL.
So if if something is um defined
you know the same entity name like oh
wheat flower is defined in two different
vocabularies ostensibly they have
different URLs or different prefixes and
so they're differentiated that way. Now
trouble is you may have um some
vocabulary that imports and tries to
redefine other vocabularies. I've seen
that happen in which case you might get
some namespace conflicts. Um, just have
to work that out. Generally speaking,
it's not a good not a good design to to
try to to redefine somebody else's
inside your namespace. Um, but I've seen
it happen and um, you know, the
well-defined vocabularies won't have
that. Um
James James makes a good point about
exact masters same as Yeah. So if you
have things that are related that are
similar like
you know maybe one vocabulary is talking
about dried basil and another one is
talking about dried basil leaves. Um so
then you want to have ways of of being
able to define
how similar are these things? Are they
duplicates? um are you know is one a
subset of the other and uh James making
a really good point um there's a
standard called SCAS that's used for
developing uh taxonomies to really
describe is something a broader case or
a narrower case or an exact match or
same as um different flavors of
relationship um in terms of taxonomy um
and that's very very important
especially as you start to mix and match
from different sources maybe we're
bringing in some data sources from
food.com
other sources from USDA
um on and on and they may not perfectly
align on their definitions, but you can
go back and use some SCAS to tie them
together. There are other techniques for
this as well and it's especially useful
if you've got an industrial application
where there's a lot of different vendors
and different parts catalogs trying to
understand which parts could be
substituted for each other. It's
important if you're building aircraft.
It's really important. Um, so yeah, this
is this is a a big issue as far as
managing holograph.
Um, all right. Uh, exact match. Yeah,
we'll show a little bit of scuzz later
on. Uh, very, very good. Excellent
discussion on that. Um, any other
questions so far? We're just kind of
getting started. Um,
let's see.
Okay. And also sir, you had the question
earlier about like how do we mix and
match onto or parts of ontology. We'll
be diving into this much more. I've just
shown two so far. As we develop this
example, we'll probably using about 12
different vocabularies.
Okay, great. Um, let me go back to
unpause.
All right. And now I'm I'm going to go
back into my into the examples
directory. Come on. There we go. And uh
let's see. I'll I'll click out of uh
well, whatever. I'll I'll leave that
notebook, but let me go to uh ex10.
And
sure. Okay. So, ex10. So, what we're
going to do here is start to build a
graph using RDF. And in Python, there's
a really excellent library, or I
personally think it's excellent. Um,
it's called RDFlib. And uh, let me
And you you won't need to use this for
these examples, but the documentation is
online. Um, rdflib.readthedocs.io.
And and a lot of what we're doing is
built around RDF is kind of a foundation
uh, at least for one part of KGLAB. Um,
so RDF I I will say it has kind of
everything but the kitchen sink. um you
know it handles serialization
uh it handles sparkle it handles some
inference um there's a lot of things you
can do um but then there's other plugins
there's other libraries that are built
on top of this so for instance we'll be
using pyshackle uh which is built on top
of rdf lib to do shackle implementation
um there's some pretty good
documentation it's not my favorite
documentation of an open source project
in the world um I I find that RDF lib
docs are kind of written for people who
are already experts in RDF lib. Um so we
try to work around that and everything
that we have in KGAB um you may have
noticed but we sorry um you may have
noticed but um
we have uh a lot of wrappers around
whatever we're calling and then flip
this back up. I should mention that if
you go to KG lab docs over on the lefth
hand side there's uh a list here of the
different sections. One of them is
called technical reference and we've got
the package reference underneath that.
And if you click that it's got the API
docs for all the different parts of
KGLAB. And anywhere that we're wrapping
some other library like for instance RDF
lib will describe how we're wrapping it
which parameters we're using what
defaults there are and just give a
little bit more background. So um you
know not to get too pedagogical but the
way that we're building the docs is from
the perspective of somebody who's
beginning who's trying to learn this and
and doesn't understand uh you know
expertise about working with individual
libraries already but is really
approaching it more from a conceptual
level and then trying to get hands-on
experience. That's how our docs are
built. Um a lot of these libraries are
sort of just we're the developers and
we're going to implement what we
implemented. So, it's from a an expert
perspective. So, I we're trying to back
fill. That's what I'm saying. All right.
Having said that, um I'm over in EX10
and we'll just our magic line at the top
to set up the paths. We'll get that
first. Okay. We'll say import RDF lib.
What I'm going to show is how to build a
graph, a small graph uh sort of in the
raw uh just simply using RDF lib. We'll
do that and then we'll show doing the
same thing with kgab. So we'll show a
contrast of hopefully how we make this
simpler. So first off import RDFlib and
then we instantiate a graph object which
will be the variable G.
Should be quick. It's a blank graph. And
now working in RDF there's a concept of
of um how do you make a statement? And
so every statement is sort of this
grammatical construct. It's called a
triple um or at least the base case of
it is a triple. Um, but you've got three
parts that are really important. There's
the subject, which is the entity that
you're talking about. There's a
predicate, which is a relationship
between the subject and something else.
And then there's an object, and the
object is is what you know the subject
is relating to. Um, it could be some
other node, some other entity in the
graph. It could be a literal value. Um
so you know you might say that anytime
crepes as an entity is our subject and
the predicate is cooking time and then
the object might be a literal value 8
minutes. Um so by by building a graph
the interesting thing is you know a
graph is composed out of nodes and edges
um vertices and arcs however you want to
describe it. I'll typically talk about
nodes and edges,
but by having this construction of a
triple, a subject, predicate object, you
can build very complex graphs. Um, but
then at the same time, it's really just
a collection of subject predicate
object. Um, so there's a couple
different ways to think of a graph, how
to construct it, also how to iterate
through it.
Um, and so when we're representing here,
uh, starting to build our graph, anytime
grapes, let's take the URL for anytime
grapes, which was what we have right
here.
Um, and that's.com,
etc. And we've got the ID. And then
we're going to wrap it with an RDF lib
call. We're going to create something
called a URI ref. And that will give us
a subject node. So you can see what
comes back in RDF lib is this object in
Python and that will be what we'll use
for a subject. That's an entity we've
created out of the blue. Um
and we're going to think about this as
something called a persistent
identifier. Um in this this name space
from food.com they've got unique
identifiers for all the recipes these
codes here 327593.
So this is going to be a kind of
identifier that we'll have for this
anytime crepe recipe. Um you know from
henceforth
uh we'll use that to reference this
recipe
and and there's a a a broader concept
called persistent identifiers where if
you're talking about somebody's paper
there might be a DOI identifier where
anywhere in the world we can give you a
URL pointer for this paper. um even if
they shift publish you know they they
move to publish republish in a different
journal let's do a URL to redirect or
another kind of persistent identifier
might be uh if you're a researcher you
probably have a an orchid identifier I
have one um so for anybody doing
research can look up their orchid ID and
then we can you know put their
information into a graph and identify
different people talking about books
there's ISBN's journals there's ISSN's
there's a lot of notion of identifiers
but those typically are something to
that are unique and persistent for the
sake of subjects.
Um, another thing that we'll be doing is
building out relationships in the graph.
So, the first predicate we'll introduce
here is um, it comes out of RDF. It's
called RDF.type
and it's a way think of of like
inheritance in object-oriented
programming. We're gonna say that our uh
our first recipe is of type uh WMT
recipe. So going back to the food
ontology, we'll say W&T colon recipe. Um
and we'll say that our our subject there
um we're going to build it out of that
type.
You see what comes back here? This is a
long reference going back into the RDF
spa space uh the RDF namespace um where
you can start to define sort of class
hierarchies.
Okay, the next thing I'm going to do is
in RDF lib there's something called a
namespace manager. It's a little
difficult I find to use not quite
intuitive but basically we're going to
create this object and then we can add
URLs to create namespaces add prefixes
etc. And and as mentioned, Brad made an
excellent suggestion. There's something
called prefix.cc
um if you go to prefix um wmt. Let's see
what we got here. Ah, nothing. Okay. Um
let's try something else.
Um, so there's a lookup here. And what
this provides is a a custom search, if
you will, uh, to be able to look up
these different kinds of vocabularies.
What is their unique canonical URL
that's being used? In some cases, there
may be some alternatives. Um, also, what
is the prefix that's being used? In this
case, SCAS. Um, it's it's a really super
helpful uh resource because coming back
here, these prefixes like RDF and WTM
and IND, they're conventions and you
hope that you use them consistently
within your knowledge graph, within your
instance of your knowledge graph. Um, if
you don't use them consistently, RDF lab
will scream and throw errors at you. Um,
but there's no guarantee that the
conventions that you use are going to be
something that another person uses for
the exact same namespace. Um, so using a
tool like prefix.cc is a way for people
sort of to align on what names they're
going to be using.
Um, all right. So let's go and create a
definition of this WTM one out of Puton.
Uh, and so we'll get the URL for it and
we'll we'll create a URI in RDF lib and
then we'll bind that inside of the
namespace manager. Boom.
Okay. And so now the fun thing is that
um looking back here at the WTF um sorry
the WTM ontology there there's these
different components in it. But because
we've created a namespace, all we have
to do now is just say namespace dot and
whatever the name of the component is
and we will automatically be referencing
that entity off in that other remote uh
namespace. So we'll do that here
and um we'll call the recipe uh kind of
of entity. And so now we can create a a
triple
um we're going to add to our graph which
so far was blank. We've got the subject
which is anytime crepe. We've got a
predicate which is RDF type. And then
we've got uh an object which is WTM
recipe.
So we've created our first triple really
the first part of the graph. Um and now
let's add to it. Um there's another kind
of predicate has cook time.
So we'll another predicate there. And
then we'll import another U namespace.
This is called XSD and it's a way of
defining units for well it's a way of
defining a lot of metadata for different
types of literals is one of the things
that it provides. So here we've got a
number eight which is we're going to
just represent that as an integer. What
it means is 8 minutes cooking time. Um
and so to make sure of that we're going
to say okay this is eight as a string.
By that we mean it's an integer um and
it has a predicate has cook time and
we're going to assume that that's in
minutes. There's better ways to do this
but but this is a simple case. So we
added it to the graph
and then we're going to take and go back
to WTM and use another predicate called
has ingredient
uh and start to build these out. So
here's an ingredient for chicken egg.
Boom. And now we can add that
that triple into the graph to say one of
the ingredients for anytime crepe is
eggs. And then we'll do the same for
milk and flour. And now to confirm what
we've built, we'll iterate through these
triples out of the graph. So G is the
graph in RDF lib. And so SPO is a
subject predicate object. And we'll
print each one of those. And so our
graph internally is basically these
these triples, these, you know, halfozen
triples here that talk about, hey, it's
a recipe. It has a cook time and it has
three ingredients.
Okay, so that's a roundabout way of
saying if you're working with raw RDF,
especially an RDF lib, um there's a lot
of steps. Let's try this differently.
Oh, uh by the way, um before I go to
that, let me show how do you save this
using RDF lib. Um so we talk about
serializing out a graph. Um we'll use
different formats. In this case we'll
use TTL which is turtle sort of this
simplified view of of RDF. Um so what
I'll do is I'll serialize it and just
print out the string. You can see here
I've got the uh prefixes and namespaces
of the top and then I've got one entity
which is our recipe and then I've got
hey it is a recipe. It's got a cook
time. It's got three ingredients. So
that's that's our graph. That's what
you'd save in a file. Um, and similarly,
if you want to just store directly to a
file, boom, we'll do that. And then
suddenly you should have a file that was
just generated. Same thing.
Um, alternatively, there's another
format called JSONLDD. Uh, linked data
version of JSON. Um, so I'll write that
out and then it will create this temp
JSON LD file. same information formatted
as a JSON file. It's a little bit easier
for machine readable applications
because frankly uh you know you have to
have some sort of special parser to be
able to read turtle but you know so many
different languages support reading JSON
files. Um so if you want to take and
serialize out your graph and then read
it in a web app JSLD is pretty good.
Ergo, Google's been pushing this having
JSONLDLDD inside of web pages for search
engine optimization.
Um, one of the things about JSONLDLD
though is they have this notion of a
context. Uh, so they're going to want to
have some metadata about your graph.
They're going to want to enumerate all
the different prefixes, namespaces for
your vocabularies. They're going to want
to know things like what language is it
in. So, we'll just create a dictionary
in Python and then there's your context.
So when you serialize out, boom. Now if
I dig up the JSON file, it should have
Sorry. Now if I dig up the JSON file, it
should have that information. Yeah.
Okay. So it's got the context, the
language, etc. A little bit more
readable that way.
Um, okay. That's the hard way to do it.
And now what I want to do is cut over
real quick into showing how to do this
in KGLAB. So up at the top um our magic
path correction and then what we'll do
is we'll import kgab as a library and
we'll create a dictionary of our name
spaces kind of the context thing and
then we'll create an object that's
called a knowledge graph out of kg and
we'll tell it hey you're going to be a
recipe knowledge graph based on foodcom
and you've got some name spaces and that
will create a variable that we'll work
with henceforth uh called kg.
Boom.
So, okay, that should happen pretty
quick. Um, once you've got that kg
object, you could call it anything. It's
just a variable, but we're going to call
it kg. Um, now we've got a lot of
shortcuts. And so, now if we want to go
back in and do all of the above, all we
have to do is say, well, you know, I
want RDF lib because I I'm I'm going to
use some literals. I'm going to create
some nodes for our graph. So, I'm going
to create uh the the recipe node, and
then I'm going to go in and add to the
KG uh object. I'm going to say take that
recipe node, and I'm going to look up
the namespace for RDF, use an RDF type,
and I'm going to look up the name space
for WTM, use WTM recipe. I'm going to
add that to the graph. Then, I'm going
to add the cooking time. And in this
case, get a little bit more fancy. We're
going to say the literal instead of just
eight as an integer, we're going to use
a duration
uh kind of of way of representing
literals in XSD. We're going to say this
is a a a time of 8 minutes and we have a
formal way of looking at that and making
it in machine interpretable.
And then we've got the different
ingredients too. So basically by using
kg lab we're able to you know just use a
half dozen lines of Python and boom uh
you should have your graph. Let's
iterate through it. So you know the same
thing that we had before. Hopefully it's
a lot less steps. Now if you want to
serialize let's go back over that again
too. Um same thing. It's just you know
much simpler way to do this. Uh also we
fixed some bugs and we've tried to make
the serialization routines much more
reliable. Um, so that's that's one
benefit. Uh, we'll save this in
different formats. Um, if you want, you
could save it as XML. So, let me dig
that up. Here's the same thing in XML.
Um, saving it as JSONLDD,
etc. Um, and the point that I want to
make there is that what we're
representing the data and the metadata,
the graph relations in all these
different serialization formats, and
really there's like a dozen of them. um
they're pretty much representing all the
same information and with a couple of
lines of Python you can read and write.
You can convert from one to the other.
So there's nothing particularly sacred
about any one of these representations.
Some have a few extra features in them
like quads. Um but in general if you're
just talking about representing triples,
you can go back and forth very simply.
So there's a lot of I've heard, you
know, culture wars between like Jason LD
versus turtle, none of that. two lines
of Python, you can go back and forth.
But the thing that's not represented in
RDFlib is something called parquet. And
so, um, I'll represent this. Um, in
parquet, uh, it's used a lot in big
data. It's called columner storage. And
it's much much more efficient for
handling a lot of data. It turns out
parquet is super efficient for handling
graphs. And it also makes it so that you
can use tools like data stacks or data
bricks uh rapids a lot of the kinds of
big data and data science tools that
expect parquet format if we if we store
it that way coming out of kg lab it's a
lot easier to use with the other tools
also it's an order of magnitude faster
and smaller um so there's just really
you can actually you can store more
metadata with parquet as well so um this
is a very very small graph it's not
going to show it actually Here there's
some overhead. Parquet turns up. It
looks larger in this instance because we
just have one entity. But once you get
into a larger graph, the numbers here
shift dramatically. Paret becomes much
faster and much smaller.
Okay, I've spent a lot of time in these
first two notebooks because I really
wanted to cover some of the basics.
Actually, the first three were
notebooks. Um, I'm going to go at a much
faster pace moving forward, but uh,
let me check back here and see if there
are any problems. What ontology would
you recommend for using? Oh, good. Okay,
so Sarah has a question. What ontology
to represent units? Great, great
question. Um, so there they're inside of
XSD. Um there's a lot of units that are
being represented although there are
others really depending on the kind of
application because it can be somewhat
application specific. Um certainly um
okay great thank you Barrett uh Yukon is
another one actually let's look that up
and see um so for instance if somebody
tells you that there's an interesting
one okay great there's uh yukum and then
let's go look that one up let's go
directly to it that's what's really nice
about working these controlled
vocabularies is generally speaking
they're URLs they're web pages not
exactly but they can they look as if
they're web pages. Um, that gets into a
lot more internals of REST and
representation. Um, but you know, the
thing is you can you can go out and
browse them and and see what's in there.
Um, this is coming off of Pearl. Well, a
lot of these vocabularys are are uh on a
particular um
I think it's on the same site. Anyway,
taking a while to load, but um we'll see
what's going on there. Let me go back to
other questions. Um, Luis,
no module names Cudith. Interesting. Um,
oh, okay. Well, let me go back to the
question. Uh, Kud,
sorry. Qudt.
Um,
yeah, I'm not familiar with Qudt. I'll
look up that one, too. And then Luis,
you have a question about um
um CUDA DF. And as far as how the
library is set up, you shouldn't be
seeing that. So that's a bug if it's
showing up. Is anybody else having the
problem with um coodf? Because the way
we've wrapped it is if you don't have
GPUs, that's not a problem. Um it should
fail over and instead just be using
Python, no Python.
Um let me take a look and see.
the GPU. Yeah, that's wrapped.
Interesting. Okay, so it's throwing an
exception. Um, wow. Okay, we've been
testing this in a lot of places and
there's a
that's in the util part. Interesting.
Okay, I'll I'll have to dig down and and
start to reproduce this one. Um, thank
you very much, Lee, for for reporting
that. Um,
oh, but you are running with Nvidia GPU.
Oh, oh, I get it. I get it. Okay. Yeah.
Um, my apologies. I I I need more
coffee. Oh, really? Um, yeah. So, what
we're doing under the hood here is
there's a number of libraries that
Nvidia provides open source. Um, there's
KUD QDF, which is a GPU optimized
version of pandas. There's QML, which is
a GPU optimized scikitlearn. There's
Kougraph, which is GPU optimized network
X. Um, we've actually been working with
Nvidia. They're one of our clients. Um,
and working with the leads. Um, some of
whom have been checking out KGAB, but
they've helped us out. Um, so yeah,
actually what we do is we detect if you
have GPUs, we go in and detect that and
then just make the assumption that you
had those those Rapids libraries
installed. And that's not a good
assumption. So, my apologies, Lee. Um uh
if you're working with cond
install um um CUDF KUDF uh and I can
help out on that. Um but um I thank you
for finding that. I'll need to wrap that
better.
Um
if there's a way if this is causing
problems for you, if there's a way on
your system to turn off your GPU, I know
that like on my laptop I can do that
pretty quickly. um that that might be
probably the best workaround.
And anybody else if you're seeing any
problems with installations or GPUs?
Yeah. Okay, turn it off. That sounds
good. Great.
Okay. Um first hour in. We took a long
time to talk about name spaces and
setting up graphs and kind of the basics
of serialization and RDF. This will be
foundational. We'll be using this over
and over throughout the day. I really
wanted to spend time on that. Let me
pick up the pace a little bit and start
showing some applications um of of what
we're doing here.
So, I'm gonna take this down. I'm gonna
clear out a few files here.
Okay great.
And now I'm going to go to ex20.
Load that up.
Okay. And so what we're going to do is
go back into our recipes.csv CSV file
and we're going to create
a graph that doesn't just have one
entity, it has a number of entities
about 300. So, first line and then we'll
come in here. We'll create a graph.
>> Just a quick one, Paco, you're paused in
presenting.
>> Oh, very very sorry. Very, very sorry.
>> No worries.
>> Okay, great. Sorry. Let me back up a
bit. Um, I just loaded
ex20
of load this notebook and I'm going to
run again the top uh set of paths and
then I'm going to go back in. Same thing
again. I'm going to import kg and I'm
going to create a namespace uh a set of
namespaces. This time I'm adding another
one called sc that allows you to build
taxonomies. Um, we'll use it for a
little bit here. And we'll create a
knowledge graph object. Boom.
Um, and just for kicks, if you ever want
to see what you've got loaded up into
Huh.
Let me restart this. For some reason,
this one is not Sometimes in Jupiter,
you may have to restart things. Um, so
let me restart this kernel.
and rerun because it just wasn't
responding.
Okay, great. That's better. Sometimes it
gets stuck. Jupiter's like that. Um,
I've created this object. Sometimes it's
interesting if you've pulled together a
lot of different vocabularies just to
print out what you've got. So, we've got
describe.ns
describe_s and that'll just give you
back a data frame that gives you all the
prefixes and the name spaces. So by
default there's some of these namespaces
that are foundational. You use them over
and over again. RDF, RDFS,
uh schema, XSD, um owl, um prov DCT.
These are just basic things that are are
used over and over so often. We include
them by default. If you want, you can
tear them out. Um there's ways to get
rid of that, but we do include them by
default. They shouldn't be any problem
if you don't invoke them. Um, okay. Now,
what I'm going to do is
come back here and create a dictionary
that says for certain types of key
phrases, I'm going to map those to known
ingredients out of our uh ind uh
vocabulary.
And
it's not a lot of them. There's a couple
dozen, but you know, common ingredients
and recipes. And the idea here is what
we're going to do is just extract out
the recipes that that have these
ingredients represented. So we're going
to work with a medium-sized graph this
way, not a ginormous huge graph. Um, but
it'll be a way of of converting from a
CSV file into a graph.
Okay. And so now what I'm going to do is
again create a Pandanda data frame from
recipes.csv.
And then I'm going to come in and
iterate through, take a look at all the
different rows in that data frame. And
for each one, I'm going to look up what
are the ingredients, and then add them
into the graph. Uh, sorry. Well, here we
for each recipe, we add it into the
graph. But then we're going to look up
and see for each ingredient, we're going
to add that ingredient into the graph.
We're also going to add in um a literal
to describe a SCA definition. You'll see
this in a moment, but basically taking
the string title of the recipe and
creating that as a Scots definition. Uh
we're going to format out in minutes
what is the cook time. So basically this
is a way of ingesting a CSV file and
coming up with an RDF graph. Boom.
And now um okay, let's let's visualize
that. Um so we'll cover visualization a
little bit later. This is just a few
lines of Python to say I'm going to take
my object, my KG object, and I'm going
to create a tensor out of it. Uh, I'm
going to represent it as a different
kind of algebraic object and then I'm
going to use that to populate PI viz.
So, couple of lines of Python and I'm
going to create an interactive
visualization. Boom. Okay. And that
generates some Python, sorry, some HTML
and some JavaScript. As you'll see, it's
loading here. Um, so I've got about 250
different recipes
or some set of recipes I should say.
Okay, great. So here's an interactive
representation. The the uh the orange
thing at the middle of this graph is the
notion of a recipe. So in terms of
ontology, the recipe is the most central
thing, right? Because we're we're
representing a lot of different recipes.
But kinds of recipes, that's
interesting. So the light blue dots uh
let's see if it works. Those are
different individual recipes. The dark
blue dots are ingredients. And the thing
that this visualization shows is that
the most commonly used ingredients are
going to show up as more central.
They're going to be closer to the the
core of the definitions. So, if you look
at the the grouping here, this cluster
of dark blue dots, you'll see salt,
uh, flour, um, butter, and milk. You can
make a lot of things with salt, butter,
flour, and milk. And then moving out a
little bit, we'll add some water or
maybe we'll add some sugar. Um, moving
further up, we've got some olive oil,
and we've got garlic, and we've got
things that don't show up in every
recipe. Um, so that's kind of a
representation then of like I say 250
recipes and you know really a couple
dozen ingredients. How do they all fit
together in a graph? And you can see the
relationships between them. If I were to
take honey and pull it, I can stretch it
out here and all of the different
recipes that we have represented in this
graph that use honey, they start to
track along.
Okay. So just interesting uh kind of
representation.
Another thing while we're here, we've
just ingested sort of a medium-siz graph
or actually it's pretty small, but we'll
call it medium size. I want to show a
little bit about comparing performance
of serialization because when you're
working with graphs of scale, this is
actually a really important matter. So,
what I'm going to do is import the time
library and we're going to have a way of
saving off a file and then figuring out
how much time did it take to save that
file in that format. So I just did
turtle file and now I'm going to save
also as XML JSONLDD and then parquet.
Boom. And now let's take a look at that.
Okay, great. Um, and so what this is
showing is that uh the same exact graph
represented four different ways. You can
see that XML is pretty large. Um, and we
know about that. Um, and you know it
takes a while. Uh, turtle is actually
fairly readable, fairly compact, but
it's kind of slow to write. Um, JSLD
somewhere in the middle, but what's
interesting here is you get order of
magnitude reduction in file size uh,
with parquet. And the write time is also
much better than turtle. And frankly, if
you the interesting thing about parquet
is it has to load on its first
invocation. So if I go back here and
rerun these, boom, boom.
You'll note that the right time for
parquet drops dramatically. It cut more
than a half by 50%. Um because some of
that overhead is has been accounted for
already. So with parquet it's really
good for doing sharding and like taking
a large data set and cutting it up into
different partitions and then
serializing those partitions in
parallel. And because of that you get
these right times. There's much much
lower uh file sizes overall are much
lower. There are other techniques such
as predicate pushdown uh which you know
basically when you go to query there's a
lot of optimizations uh there's
compression that's built in etc etc. So
um parquet is turning out to be much
much better for graphs although it's not
a default built-in thing.
Um, okay. So, that is building up a
graph and then, uh, let me cut over to,
um, I'm going to go to, uh, ex30 and
we'll, we'll dig into a little bit more
about visualizing graph. So, I'm going
to back up a bit and show what we did
with Py Viz. There's a library called PI
Viz and what it does is to generate HTML
and JavaScript so that you can visualize
interactively with a graph. I'm going to
create a I'm going to use PI viz in the
raw first just to show what it's like
and how to drill down to it and then
I'll show it wrapped up in KG lab. So
here I'm going to create a very very
simple graph just three elements and
some relations between them and put this
raw into pi. Boom.
And that should create yeah just this
very very simple graph here. Um, so
we've got fooar and boss and then some
relationships between them. Fu bar and
xyz y.
Um, now let's do the same thing using kg
lab. Um, actually we'll use a larger
graph. Um, so what we're doing is here's
I'm going to take and and load one of
those files that we had saved off in the
last notebook. Um, actually it's really
interesting if I if I dig up temp.tl tl
turtle. Um here's the graph that we've
been working with in turtle
representation and you can see the
different recipes. Um you can see like
here's one for frosting. Um here's one
for simple popovers and for each one
you've got its duration, you've got its
ingredients and it label on and on and
on.
Um so let's take this graph that we have
and visualize it again. Um, again, it's
real simple, just a couple lines of
Python. We're going to convert from our
graph into what we call a subgraph. So,
we're basically converting it into a
tensor, like a matrix. Um, and then we
use that to build out Pybiz.
I'm also going to throw in one other
part. We have a a style object. So for
each one of the namespaces there
optionally if you want it's not needed
but um optionally for each different uh
prefix each namespace for the relations
in that prefix you can give it some
styling some design. So in this case the
WTM vocabulary will be colored in orange
give it size 40 and then the the
ingredients will be colored in blue and
give it size 30. And when I run that,
boom. Okay, now I've created a PI viz
graph and then I'm going to render it
interactively here in the browser. Um,
so in in visualization, there's
different different types of dynamic
visualization. In this case, we're using
something called force atlas 2. Um, and
we'll save it off to an HTML file so we
can dig it up later. But those lines
will render it.
And this will be the same thing we
looked at before, but I'm just trying to
break down what were those elements. How
did they get there? All we had to do was
just say, well, you know, if you've got
an ingredient, it's coming from a
particular vocabulary, we're going to
have that in dark blue. Um, if you've
got a a class of a food kind of thing,
like a recipe that's a little bit larger
and it's an orange and everything else
is defaulting out to a light blue.
So, um, you can really go through this
in much more detail. Um, oh, by the way,
there's also, you know, zoom and drag.
Um, if you zoom out to a far enough
level, you'll see all the labels. It's
kind of noisy, though.
But, um, the nice thing is, um, when you
create a visualization with PI is, you
can literally just save it off as an
HTML file. And that's the file that we
called it was temp 3. And if you dig
that up over here,
okay, great. We've got some HTML. Um,
you could take that and put it into a
web app. You could put it into a
standalone page. Um, you know, you can
you can embed it in a lot of types of
applications. It'll take a little bit
longer to learn it there. Um, okay. So,
that now we're working with a larger
graph. A little bit of a of an
introduction to some tools for
visualization. Let me cut back over and
see pause sharing and see if there's any
questions.
Oh great.
Okay, good. And so, uh, Barrett, you had
a good question there. Um, JSONLDLD was
fastest and then the second time around,
Parket was faster. Yeah. So, what's
interesting there is what Paret does is
something called a dictionary
compression or at least by default. Um,
you kind of got to dig into the way that
we're using it is we call pandas, pandas
calls arrow, arrow calls paret. Um, and
if you're using rapids with GPUs,
there's there's another light couple of
libraries that get in there between. But
what happens is that when you've got a
graph that's represented as subject,
object, predicate, and maybe some other
information, too. You've got all those
triples. Basically, you've got a big uh
column or storage for the graph. So,
you've got three columns or more if
there's some other metadata, but then
you've got a row for every triple.
What what parquet does is to use uh in
this case dictionary uh uh compression
which says that for each column I'm
going to look at all the different
instances of strings that show up in
that column and I'm going to map them to
numbers and I'm going to compress them
based off of that dictionary. And so
that's really cool for working with RDF
graphs because you know the predicates,
we'll look at this later, but the
predicates there's not that many of
them. So far, we've only used like a
half dozen different predicates. I could
have a million different entries in the
graph, maybe only a dozen different
predicates. And so that column can just
bam be compressed into a very small
space. And similarly with the entities,
you're going to make a lot of links and
references amongst the entities. There's
probably many more links than there are
actual entities. So you're going to see
the subjects and the predicates being
repeated many, many, many times.
Similarly, when you take the full URL,
then parquet will put those in a
dictionary, boom, compress them. So,
what happens is you get this overhead
the first time you do it, you're
building up your dictionaries and also
loading some of the libraries. Um, but
when you see subsequent runs of parcade,
they'll be a lot a lot faster. And uh
Sarah, good question. Is there a more
human readable visualization to see the
superior structure and not only the
instances that are connected? Very good
question. Um, yeah. So, uh, good
question, Sarah. what what you could do
there um another thing you can do is to
query the graph first and then visualize
the results of the query. So you may
want to pull out as you're saying some
of the superructure another word for
that is what's called a backbone and
you'll hear the term multiscale backbone
for instance being used. Um, so you
might want to use a sparkle query and
pull out the parts of the graph that
you're really interested in visualizing
and consider that to be your subgraph
and then visualize that. We'll show some
examples of that a little bit later on.
Um, and then Barrett, does Parquet help
with two-way relationships between
concepts, if that makes sense? Often you
build it one way then forget the other
way. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's great. Um,
okay. Thanks, Sarah. Yeah. Uh, Brett,
that that great question. Um, when
you're representing relationships
between different kinds of entities, it
may be bjective. Uh, and that's a
mathematical term. And I can get in real
trouble because the mathematicians have
very nuanced ideas about bjectivity, but
let's just say that it that let's just
say that you've got some kind of
relationship. It can go in either
direction. So, um, you know, uh, if I
were going back to my Viking example,
um, that I mentioned earlier, um, you
know, life is son of Eric,
uh, but then Eric is parent of life. Um,
and when you're working with RDFS and
owl and constructing these kinds of
relationships, you will have inverse
relationships that can be automatically
mapped. And the nice thing about working
with RDF graphs is you don't have to
specify those explicitly. You can use
something called inference which we'll
show where you fill those in. And
typically if you're going to be doing
some analysis of a graph um you know
such as doing shackle applying shackle
rules you'll want to run that inference
first to sort of populate out all the
missing parts. Um that's generally
called inference closures uh is another
name for that. Um, but it's how you fill
in those two-way relationships, even if
they're not explicitly known. If you
have one half of the relationship, you
can infer the other half. Really good
question.
Okay, great. Um, we're an hour and a
half in. Uh,
James, should we take a a bio break?
Give people uh maybe five minutes to
take a break.
Sorry.
>> Yep. Um yeah, sure. Go go go go go for
it. Um yeah, so there's there's half an
hour left and because there's backtoback
session, um I'll need to leave probably
to get ready for that. But um sure.
>> Oh. Um Oh, wait. We have a half hour
left. Oh, I was thinking it was longer.
Sorry.
>> Uh in that case, if we've only got a
half hour left, we're only we're only
going to 11 Pacific. So, it's a two-hour
master class, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Okay. Um, in that case, since it's the
shorter time, let's not do the break.
We'll go through this a lot quicker. Um,
there's definitely more things we want
to cover. Um, some questions. So, um,
uh, let me jump in.
I'm going to go back and let me share.
Unpause sharing. Okay. So, um, we were
just talking about queries. I'm going to
load up EX4 and we'll go through this
real quick, but very simple to do
queries. Um, do the magic path thing
first. There's something called Sparkle,
which is a standard query language for
RDF. U, there's other kinds of quering
of graphs. Uh, but but Sparkle is is
very very popular. So, what I'm going to
do is define
a different graph. This one here has
three people, and we're using a
vocabulary called friend of a friend, fo
af. Um,
okay. And now we'll we'll just bring
this into we'll we'll create an RDF lib.
We're going to show how to do this in
raw RDF lib first. And we'll show how to
do it in uh in KG. So I'm going to
define a query that says I'm going to
look for a person and their surname and
their email. I'm going to do that by
finding triples that match these two
patterns. I've got a person. They've got
a FOF a friend of a friend family name
is a relationship and particular surname
and then they've got an inbox which is a
relationship for an email address. So
basically by filling in substituting the
variables here these two relationships
are a kind of shape in the graph that
I'm looking at through the sparkle
query.
I'm going to find all the instances that
match and then collect out these
variables up here. person, surname, and
email. Also, I'm going to sort them in
order uh descending.
So, that's very similar to SQL queries.
If you used these before, it's a little
bit more complicated. There's a few
different kinds of things we added, but
um it's similar. So, I'll take an RDF
graph, RDF lib graph, and I'll call
query with sparkle query. And then I'm
just going to iterate out and show as
each row in the result set as a
dictionary.
Great. Um, and as you can see, here's
email person's surname that's being
matched. Patel O'Neal Makamoto.
Um,
and if I want, I could I could populate
this a little bit more. I could take and
convert some of these uh different
literals into something that's a little
bit more of a Python data structure.
Great. Now, let's show doing the same
thing though with KGLAB. So here I've
got a graph I'm going to define using my
my fragment before of three friends
and
oh sorry um I'm actually going to use my
food graph. Sorry minal slip there. Um
I'm loading up my temptl the recipes
database that we've shown before. Um,
and now I'm going to I'm going to query
it. And instead of asking for person,
surname, and email, I'm going to ask for
recipe and then definition of the
recipe, the label, and the cooking time.
But it's it's very similar. We're we're
keying off recipe and its relationship
as recipe RDF type, and then for a
recipe, what's its cause definition? And
then what are the ingredients and cook
time, and again, sort descending by
time.
Okay, so that's just a string, but
that's our query. And here, what I'm
going to do is I'm importing pandas
because I want to visualize this. I'm
going to call our kg variable, our our
knowledge graph. I'm going to say query
as df data frame with that sparkle
string. And what I'm going to get back
is a data frame representing the
results. I just show the top 20. Um, so
this is a a convenience. uh the result
set is coming back as a dataf frame
which means I can go and operate on that
with scikitlearn or something else that
expects data frames. You can see the
formatting there. We got recipe duration
and time. Now it's interesting looking
at these um you know most of these
recipes that are coming back in the
query. They're like an hour and a half
long, right? They're typically baking
cookies will take you an hour and a
half. Some of these things though are
taking a lot longer. Um here's eggnog
takes an hour, sorry, one day and 30
minutes. Uh so that's interesting. Um
there's definitely a lot of distribution
when it comes to we'll use that a little
bit later on. Um okay so let's do some
post-processing from the queries. Um so
again we've got our recipes and in this
case I'm going to go to a slightly
different file. It's under DAT and um
and here what we've done is to add a bit
more taxonomy. So we've got this notion
from SCAS that we're going to start to
uh define some things that are done to
recipes. So uh got a concept of process
food processing. And you'll notice that
we're linking out to some other
resources here. We're using DCT
vocabulary identifier to link out to
Wiki data. And here's a a food
processing web page on Wiki data. Um
here is mixing as a type of food
processing. And there's a SCAS closer
match to food talking about mixing and
blending as a type of food process. So
we're using our a little bit more
sophisticated use of the food ontology.
Uh kneading is a is something in
contrast to mixing. So if you're making
bread, you're kneading. If you're making
crepes, you're mixing. Um and here we've
got RDFS where uh we're defining a bit
of a relationship um in terms of of
describing food processing. Um and we're
going to use this then to say let's
start to look at our
our food recipes as kinds of dishes that
we're preparing. And some of these are
based off of creating dough and kneading
the dough. Um, and then some of them are
create based off of creating a batter
and then mixing the batter. Um, and in
particular, we have some instances.
We've got pancakes like crepes or we've
got noodles like dumplings. Um, and that
was something I noticed when I was
looking at the recipes because some of
these the the dumplings take like two
days to prepare. Some of the Eastern
European recipes are pretty interesting
that way. Um, so what we're doing is
basically taking this is like an
additional components of vocabulary that
we we're creating on the fly by reusing
owl and scholars and other things and
now we're going to add that in to what
we had from our recipes. So what we're
saying is we've loaded up what we had
before but now in addition we're going
to do this additive thing and load up
nom.tl.
So it's just added into there. And now
when we start to um do the sparkle
query, let's take a look at some
results. We'll do some post-processing.
Um so again, we're going to try to go
after recipes that have egg, flour, and
salt as we saw in crepes, but there's a
lot of different kinds of recipes that
combine those three ingredients. Um so
here, let's tally them up. And so what's
interesting is that when you look at
these, most of the recipes that have
eggs, flour, and salt, they're going to
be either some type of pasta or some
type of of noodle or some type of bread,
some type of batter. Um, and we're going
to take a look at inside of the names.
We're going to do a little bit
lightweight text analysis and say, hey,
if it's if it says noodle in the
description, we'll call it that. this is
dumpling. It says in German or pasta in
Italian. Um we'll call it that. We'll
say that it's a type of noodle. But
we'll also take a look and see, you
know, does that recipe have an
additional ingredient of butter? Um and
this is interesting because now we can
start to apply some some rules on top of
our sparkle query.
Okay. And we'll tally these up and and
looking at this, I'm going to use a
mosaic plot. Um, but we build up a table
that says, hm, you know, it turns out,
uh, there's a conditional probability of
it says it's a noodle and it has butter
in the recipe versus it has butter or it
says that it's a noodle. Um, long story
short, what we're going to do is come up
with a simple rule to try to
differentiate are we working with a kind
of of noodle or we working with kind of
pancake. Now, there's other types of
recipes. If you're from the UK, you're
probably familiar with something called
the Yorkshire pudding. Um, there's other
things that use eggs and flour, but a
lot of the recipes are we're going to at
least try to pull out which ones are
noodles and pancakes. And as it turns
out from manual review, we've picked out
a few of the recipes just to be able to
train on.
Um,
okay, great. So, what we've done here is
that for each of the the IDs that I
could manually pick out as being a
noodle or being a pancake, um what we're
going to go back in is annotate them
using this nom uh over here, these
extended vocabulary that we did. Uh
we're going to annotate those recipes
and say, "Okay, I know you're a noodle
recipe or I know you're a pancake." And
so now if we go back in and take a look
at our temptl file, um the thing that
we're building up, we've just serialized
out uh temptl. Boom.
And now you can find if I look up crepe
anytime.
Okay great.
So now, you know, we've got our recipes
in there. But if I go back and look at
this identifier for anytime craps.
Okay. Uh then we should have definitions
in there
toward the bottom.
Okay. Great. So now we should have
definitions added to this annotating
whether or not something is a noodle or
a a batter.
Um and and the idea here is what I'm
trying to bring out is that we've got a
graph. We can apply sparkle queries to
it, but we can do some post-processing
on the results that are coming out of
the sparkle queries. And in this case,
we came up with some conditional
probabilities to try to fry define a
really simple set of rules to
distinguish between different things
that we could go back in and add
annotations to the graph. We can get a
lot more complex with this. We can use
probabilistic rule sets. Um but you know
it's it's it's stressing the point that
you can start to complement with
different approaches. Um you can start
to mix and match between a very
deterministic kind of query versus some
sort of rule system.
Okay. Now building on that let's talk
about rule systems in a much more
defined way. Um using something called
shackle. I'm going to load up ex50
and we're using a library called
Pyshackle that's built on top of RDF
web, but we do some wrappers over the
top of it. And shackle is a way of
defining shapes. Uh if you want to look
up, there's a lot of great background on
it from WTC. It's a it's a way of
defining rules based off of shape
constraints. So again, in in a a
knowledge graph, shapes equate to data
objects. And by having rules that
describe what you expect to see in your
shapes, um, then you can start to pick
out different data objects.
So here I'm going to define some
shackle. I'm going to say I've got a
person shape and it's going to look at a
node and I'm going to expect to see that
for each person, they've got a first
name. It's going to be type XSD string
um, and called a given name. And then
they've got a birth date, gender,
address, etc. The addresses might have
postal codes.
Um, so once I've defined that, then I've
created some rules. And here I've got a
real simple graph and it's just got um,
okay, here's some people,
they live or actually a person uh,
somebody named Robert Junior who helped
to define uh, some W3C standards. I
believe what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take um this RDF and I'm going
to apply the shackle rules to it. And
this is again doing it in raw.
Boom. And shackle will print out. Okay,
here are all the parts that have
violated some rule, some constraint
shape constraint rule. Um in particular,
Bob's address didn't really fit the
postal code design designation. Also,
Bob's birthday didn't quite fit.
Okay, great. Um, and so shackles is a is
a way of creating a report, but
optionally what it reports could be
coming back as a graph.
Now, if I want, I can treat this as a
graph and I can iterate through and take
a look at at what are the different
components that are being reported.
Now, that's using shackle in the raw. If
I do this with KG Lab, uh trying to make
it a little bit simpler, we'll create a
graph out of our recipes like I
mentioned before. Um and now we're going
to do a real simple shape. Um and in
this case here, we're going to say it's
got to have at least three uh
ingredients. And the maximum length of
the definition, its label will be 50.
So, I'm going to do a little bit of a
data quality check on the recipes and
just see, let's kick out any of the
recipes that don't fit those rules.
Great. And so, we can get back our
report text.
And we can take a look and see. Okay.
Interesting. So, Proffider has too long
of a label. And looks like there's some
tabs in that label, too. Um, and also
German dumplings, spatzel, one of my
favorites. We used to make those at
home. um and yeah it's got too long of a
name um on and on and on. So the idea
that I'm bringing out here is that there
can be data quality checks expressed as
shape constraints as shackle rules. You
can apply them to your knowledge graph
in general and kick out the ones that
are exceptions and then review those.
So let's do that. Um what we're going to
do here is to take a look at this report
that came back as a graph. It's an RDF
graph. When we run shackle, instead of
getting a text report, we can get it
back as additional RDF graph. Sort of
taking a subset of our knowledge graph
and and just having the reporter parts
that we need to troubleshoot. So, we're
going to take that graph and we're going
to query it with this sparkle query to
uh get a little bit more insight on what
it is uh that that's causing the
problems and we're going to report that
as a data frame. So now we can use it in
pandas in scikitlearn etc. And so here
we've got just a small set of uh these
recipes that didn't follow the rules
that we'd had.
You can go into a lot more details with
shackle. Um the nice thing about it is
it's being used for auditing work. Um
it's also being used for for data
quality checks. It can be used for human
in the loop to sort of kick out things
that an expert should review. It can be
used for inference in certain ways. Uh
the nice thing about it is that the
rules in shackle are something that are
you know relatively easier for people to
read and understand. Let me dig back up
a rule. These this formatting of rules
is something that a domain expert who
doesn't speak knowledge graph can at
least look at and review and say yeah
this you know this fits our financial
audit. Um, so I just want to introduce
Shackle. Something very, very useful to
use. Uh, and let me cut back over real
quick and see if there are any questions
right there.
No questions just yet. Yes. Uh, Ash.
Yes, Ashley's class is coming up, so I
want to wrap up soon. Um,
okay. If no questions yet, let me keep
going. There's much more to Ah, good. Uh
Shanda, can we plug the knowledge graph
into Spacy? Ah, great question. Yes.
Yes, exactly. In fact, that's why KG lab
was created was because of spacy. Um,
and so there's another project uh that's
called pyextrank and I've been one of
the committers on uh text rank
implementation since 2009.
Um there's a python version is
relatively popular. A lot of the
developers for pyrank are also
developers on kgab. What we wanted to do
was be able to build up knowledge graphs
to represent what is being parsed out of
text in spacey pipelines. And so
pyextrank is is a pipeline component for
spacy. And uh there's something called
entity linking where you can provide a
knowledge graph and then when you're
doing NLP work when you when you
recognize entities in the text link
those into the graph and so that's what
we've been building. That's why we built
KG lab in the first place uh was to be
able to have RDF representations of you
know a thesaurus that you can apply or
like a domain specific vocabulary that
you can apply and go in and parse a
bunch of documents and pull out the
entities from the knowledge graph. So
you have everything linked into your
graph. Um and the reason for that is
that with text graph uh with text rank
and the text graph kind of algorithms
they use graph algorithms to pull out
the entities from the text. Um and so
there's a very very nice fit between the
two. Uh we don't have that ready yet to
show. We've been working on it. Um
within the next couple months we should
have a PR um where we'll be pushing that
live KG lab integration of PEX rank and
that'll be showing up on spacey
universe. Um really good question.
There's a lot of other ways to use
knowledge graph where you can um you
know in in
[Music]
you can take and and have question
answering or some type of explanability.
Um but definitely um this overlap
between NLP and knowledge graphs is
really rich. Um I recently did worked on
an industry survey about NLP use cases
in enterprise in industry and the number
four use case for NLP in industry now is
preparing for knowledge graph work um
data preparation for graphs. Um so
definitely a lot of of overlap there.
Okay, let me uh move on. There's a
couple other things I definitely want to
show.
So I'll go back to sharing. Um how do I
share this thing?
There we go. Unpuzzle. Thank you.
Um, okay. Now, uh, let me go to number
six. This gets interesting. So, I'm
going to open up ex60.
We're going to shift into a different
area al together. This is working with
graph algorithms. We're going to be
using a library called networkX. Um, and
so let me talk through here. Lot of work
in graph algorithms. It's a very very
deep rabbit hole. Uh long story short,
the area of graph algorithms typically a
lot of this work has used let's take a
graph convert it to a matrix and run
algorithms on a matrix and that works
pretty well when you're using things
like you know vector processing like the
GPUs. Um with KGAB we're managing how
you make that transform from graph data
to matrix data or graph data to tensor
data. Um, so you you've probably seen
this used before of something called a
subgraph.
What I'm going to do here is bring in
our recipes. We've got slightly larger
version of the graph that we were
working with before, but pretty much the
same thing as what we just did by adding
the non um vocabulary extension. And
here I've got a sparkle query. This goes
back to an earlier question, but I'm
going to take a look at recipes and
ingredients and represent those as just
a a sort of a a superructure uh backbone
if you will of subject and object. And
let's let's skip the different
relationships. We're just concerned
about this one kind of has ingredient
relationship. Right?
And now what I can do is create what's
called a directed graph. So in knowledge
graph there's directions on the edges.
One entity
with a relationship to another entity.
So that's directed. Um, and there's a
special kind of that called a bipartite
graph. What that says is that the
recipes,
at least in this representation that I'm
looking at, um, recipes aren't going to
link to each other. Recipes link to
ingredients. Also, ingredients don't
link to each other. The ingredients are
linked by recipes. So this is a
simplified view, but it says that the
different entities in my simplified view
are two distinct sets, bipartite sets.
That's really helpful when you're doing
uh building search indexes for instance.
Um but long story short, I'm building up
a graph in in uh network X uh by using
kg
and
now I can start to do some graph work
with it, graph algorithm work with it.
First thing, real simple. I'll just take
a look at what's called density. Uh, and
this tells you a bit about the
distribution of uh nodes and edges. Uh,
maximum possible number of edges per
node. Um, so the upper it ranges from 0
to one. So here we've got a fairly
sparse graph uh 016.
um just something interesting especially
when you get into larger graphs to
understand like how much compute will be
required.
And now let's take a look. I've got a
node ingredient for butter and I'm just
going to get an identifier for it. I'm
use a transform to get a number to
represent that. I'm going to go in and
say, hey, let's take and search all the
recipes that have butter. Starting from
that butter as a starting point, I'm
going to do a breath first search.
Actually, nothing. no edges are
returned. Um,
and so butter is a terminal node. It
doesn't connect to anything else. So
what I'm going to do is go back and and
rework this graph. I'm going to convert
it from a directed graph into just very
simply an undirected graph. So now
basically have a two-way relationship on
every edge. And if I do that, boom. Now
I can show with that simplification.
I've relaxed it. Here's, you know, if
you hop through all of the recipes that
use butter, let's hop over them and look
at the other ingredients. Look at its
neighbors.
Um, and so now I'm going to take and
look at, okay, let's cut that into sets.
I've got this bipartite relationship of
all the recipes and all the ingredients
that are somewhere clustered around
butter.
Ah, there's a lot of graph algorithms
you can use. One thing that's actually
pretty useful is something called a
topological analysis. I can do something
called a triadic census. It comes up
occasionally. Um, but it's it's a way of
understanding shapes that occur
frequently within a graph. And this
actually gets into some ways of being
able to generate sparkle and generate uh
shackle rules and things like that. It's
a it's a kind of of processing you could
do. Um,
let me go a little bit further. What
we're going to do here is take and use a
graph algorithm called centrality,
degrees centrality. We're going to take
a look and see which nodes in this
subgraph that we're working with are
most connected. As it turns out, flour,
egg, salt, those are really highly
connected. Flower is the most common
ingredient. That's one way to look at
it. Let's try to visualize that. So, we
can use mattplot lib on the results.
Boom.
And this is where having a GPU comes in
very handy.
Um,
okay. Taking a bit to show. Boom. And so
you can see this distribution of like
all the different recipes in this
subset. And then out on the edge in red,
you've got uh the different ingredients.
We can we can go in and use a different
algorithm though called Kore. And we can
take a look at the maximal connected
subgraphs. Um, so now we can start to
pull apart uh the cores, sort of peel
off the onion skin if you will, from our
graph by taking a look at the most
popular kinds of ingredients. It's a
slightly different view than just using
a centrality measure. Again, it's like
peeling off an onion skin, but what
we're trying to do is tease out the
relationships amongst all these
different types of of ingredients.
And another variation, a kind of
centrality, it's called value
centrality. um is page rank. You've
probably heard of that. And if you run
it, it comes up with slightly different
rank values, but the same rank order as
using Kore. But again, we we've we're
taking a look at some analysis of these
popular kinds of of ingredients. How do
they relate to each other within the
recipes? And we can apply rankings,
numerical uh measures of distance uh
between these different ones, which we
can use for other types of purposes
later on. So I just want to show that
that in terms of network X there's a lot
of algorithms a lot of implementations
but you can take an RDF graph and boom
within a few lines of code back up here
you can come from a sparkle query and
start to do graph algorithm analysis. It
used to be you'd have to write a lot of
custom code and that might take a few
hours to do. That's one of the things
we've tried to simplify.
Um another thing I'd like to show that's
related uh is about measurement and
inference. Um, so I'm going to load up
here X70.
Um and
I've got a different uh graph. It's one
that's got some relationships, family
members who are a bunch of Vikings, very
happy Vikings in a village. Uh, I'm
going to do a measure. So I'm going to
take a look and see how many edges are
in this graph and how many nodes. I can
come back and measure it. Let's query
it.
And here I'm going to look at who's an
ancestor of whom in the graph. And uh
[Music]
initially I don't get a lot of results.
And part of that is because this is a
twodirectional relationship that I'm
measuring spouse of um ancestor of
things like that. Those can be reflected
back.
Um, so what I'm going to do is apply
something called inference using owl uh
using an owl closure and I'm going to
fill in the missing parts. So if
somebody is a child of another node then
I'm going to fill in an additional
relationship and say well the other node
is an ancestor of that child
and it does it populates out uh if you
take a look and see it'll generate a lot
more nodes in the graph. If I come back
in and measure, you can see many more
edges, many more nodes. And if I query,
I can come back and get a lot more
answers. Um, so I just want to stress
this that you you probably want to
leverage inference um before you start
doing a lot of analysis. Um, I can do
similar things with Scotsify. I know
we're coming up on time um so I don't
want to go into too much detail on that,
but it's something to keep in mind.
There are ways to fill in the blanks in
a graph um by doing that. Um, I know
that we're almost out of time for the
two-hour slot. I'll be around. I can
answer questions. There's definitely a
lot more areas of KG lab. We can get
into some of the machine learning parts
of it. Um, in X, uh, EX71, we talk about
probabilistic graphs. And then in 8.0,
we start working with some deep learning
to dduplicate the ingredients. Um,
definitely have a lot of others about
working uh with CSV files and whatnot,
but I hear the audio. So, let me pause
and go back to
Great. Okay, some questions. Natalie,
um, can you point me to my people? I've
been using knowledge graphs to drive
systems thinking and analytics teams.
Uh, subject matter. Okay. Can you share
names of people or groups that have
specific interests uh in data science
project management? No, that's a that's
a good one. Uh, good question. Um,
project management is great and oh gosh,
there was a really incredible team that
I got a chance to talk with at General
Electric about five years ago. I got
introduced to them through my editors.
Um, they actually wanted to talk talk
shop and unfortunately I I left that
position. All of my my contacts were in
the corporate email on my previous job.
Um but inside of GE they were they were
looking at project management
particularly how to move people between
different product lines. What kind of uh
if you wanted to beef up one line and
move people off of one line to another
what kind of training would required per
individual based off of previous uh
accreditation training they had and
certification and it's important for
compliance reasons. So they were using
knowledge graph and a lot of very deep
work in ontology to represent about
people and training and product lines
and then that fit into the project
management. It was fascinating work and
I'm trying to find out where those
people are. Um but I'm I'm certainly
seeing this as sort of data data science
for project management. Um I've also
seen people who go out and do data
mining on the database of Jira tickets
for a project a software engineering
project to understand and do a graph
representation of the problems that were
encountered in project management uh and
be able to predict about costs of of new
product features. Um so we can talk more
I'd love to talk offline about that. Um
thank you very much. A lot of great
comments. Um oh great yeah love to
connect. Uh, NH did a digital brat. Yes,
I'd like to talk more about that. Um,
okay, great. Thanks for kind words.
There's a lot more we could cover, but
we could did cover a lot in in two hours
and I don't know if I have to jump off
the video if it's possible to stick
around. Um,
uh, I'm very happy to stick around and
answer questions. I'll leave that. I'm
not sure. James, what
>> I'm not sure on that. Ilas may know the
answer. I think there is a technical
seat limitation. Um but hopefully you'll
be able to comment on that. Um but yeah
just just a massive thanks from me Paco
as well because that was you know an
incredible session. I've never seen
anything like it if I'm honest in our
space and so that yeah massive thanks
and I managed to fix my Python issue and
catch up so I participated myself.
>> Thank you kindly. Well the one takeaway
is just you know there's a lot of code
out there for working with graphs. The
people in graph algorithms don't talk to
the people doing semantic technologies.
Those people don't talk to the people
doing graph neural networks. And none of
them talk to the people in statistical
relation learning. So what we've tried
to do with within a few lines of Python,
can we bridge between these different
communities instead of writing 3,000
lines of of Java, can we just write a
few lines of Python and make it simple?
That's what we're trying to do. We'd
love to work with you all. If you have
use cases or things to suggest or any
sort of issues you run into, please let
us know. And u thank you all very much
for this.